the jurogan experience that's a true
story by the way that i tell i have a
ex-girlfriend that when we first started
dating we'd been together for like a few
weeks and it was like popping off we
love each other oh my god and she left
her email open and i searched my name
thinking i would find all these great
things she's saying about me behind my
back
it was really bad and there was like a
chat like a g-chat gmail chat between
her and her best friend and she
literally was like i just met this guy i
think i'm in love with him he's the
funniest guy i've ever met i'm not
attracted to him but i'm gonna give it a
shot
and i just read it and then like you
know she comes home a few hours later
and it's like hey i'm like hey
and it's brutal it still lingers by the
way was that the end of it because no
because
i couldn't first of all i was like in
love with her and
it wasn't a confidence boost i was like
i can't go be single now knowing i'm
ugly but it's like
the person who loved me the most in the
world behind my back described me as
unattractive oh horrible yeah it's
horrible that's why i'm behind this mic
as much as i can be right now
it's horrible we had that's why we had
an easy time writing the movie too
because he has these stories so he would
just tell me stuff like that and i i
know from experience what's going to
work in a script i've written them
before i've directed him before so he
would just tell me that and i'm like
it's going in
that's got to be in here we had to
change the names of course it changed
the names of course but uh and so you're
releasing it only on your website yeah
you're not gonna put it out anywhere
else afterwards i mean we'll see you
know but right now the bet the best
mouth to drink in the interest is the
website it just goes right comes right
to us we did a big theatrical yeah
the theaters for did very well yeah for
a month and it was killing really yeah
it was um
like amc theaters and regal in a few
theaters what they do if they don't give
you a full run they just go you can have
every city for one night like it's seven
o'clock on a wednesday we were in 70
screens across the country wow and they
all sold out and doubled we're in a lot
of cities we were like in three theaters
like like like thor or something holy
[ __ ] yeah and then at the lemley in l.a
get held over like three four weeks i
think yeah it just kept getting held
over it was very in new york we had a
premiere at the beacon theater and we
packed it and everybody watched the
movie in the beacon theater and it was
that's huge [ __ ] amazing just huge
laughs i don't want to derail the
conversation my ass just fell off on the
rug and i feel terrible okay great here
that was helpful there is an ashtray but
well that fell you know sometimes yeah i
didn't hash on the right you get ash on
the table it doesn't matter all right it
fell it was a mistake it doesn't matter
yeah so people
people loved watching the movie together
i think in crowds and laughing it was
really fun to be in a cinema where
people are laughing so you can't hear
the dialogue that's like the best
feeling in the world oh man yeah it was
great it was pretty magical and there
was laughs where we didn't expect laughs
for me it's like about my life
basically my mother's much nicer i don't
know where the camera is my mother's
wonderful she's not a sociopath
but
you know to you everything about you is
dramatic and then there's moments that
happened in the movie would be like this
huge house room laugh and i was like i
didn't even think that was funny
like when the dad i don't want to give
too much away but i try to talk to my
parents and my dad just responds by
being like jesus and takes a sip of beer
i thought it was like a sad moment and
the place like big clothes would
laughter and different in each city like
we did big screenings premieres with
with us there and cast members in a
beacon and then in boston at the
schubert and then at the vic in chicago
so in bought in new york he tells his
family off the moment where he just
really lets him have it and says [ __ ]
you to his mom don't give away two
minutes too bad listen it's it doesn't
matter the new york crowd went berserk
they cheered like yeah cause we're all
in new york right we all came from some
[ __ ] town and it was a fantasy for
them and everybody's like that's right
that's right then we take the movie to
boston where everybody's from
and that moment the crowd was like oh no
[Laughter]
when he said [ __ ] you mom
oh no you don't say that
and so totally split
but then later when his uncle has that
they have this fight work that kind it
brings in both
cases brought the audience back together
because he kind of levels the thing out
and
so i to me that's a successful movie one
that it gets completely different
reactions from different people but they
all like it in there you know
is this the first time you've ever
released something just directly i know
you did your animated show you did you
released that directly on your website
oh yeah which one
pete oh yeah horse and pete that was the
the stage show yeah this is the first
thing i've made that besides stand-up
specials
um i have two new ones that just that
are out now but that's the first one
that uh yeah the first movie i've ever
put out on my site directly and you've
just been doing mostly your stand-up
specials that way right of specials also
my series louis on fx that's on my
website to exclusively i got i licensed
it from fx and from disney who actually
owns it
and so you can buy it on my website i
had i like i got them to give it to me
exclusive so i wouldn't have to compete
so if you can buy the whole series all
five seasons for five for thirty dollars
for the whole five seasons do you think
you'll ever get to a point where your
website is like a subscription thing
like a [ __ ] hulu type deal where you
could just subscribe to your website and
get all the things i think that's tough
because it's not that much content i
mean i have there's packages like you
can buy all my i have seven stand-up
hour specials on there now you can buy
them all for 25 bucks so that unlocks
all of them you can stream them you can
download them
and own them and whatever
that's just the way it's always been
between me and my fans on the website
uh i put i put stuff out once in a while
it's at a price that's
just get just enough for me to get some
profit
and get the money back you know so it
lets me operate independently and it's
outside of the kind of algorithmic it's
not the thing is that those
platforms depend on algorithmic plug-in
and it's a very different model yeah
they also have billions of dollars to
create contact in the lice license
content
um
i don't know where it's going i'm
growing it's starting to be a lot of a
lot of stuff there's a lot of stuff on
the website yeah
yeah that's what i'm getting to it's
like uh i've thought about that too
because a lot of people are starting to
do that now like schultz released his
his uh new special completely on his
website yeah and uh a lot of people are
doing those kind of things now because
you you do encounter these problems with
streaming services and
censorship and just
weird
just having their input on content it's
not fun no of course not and uh they
have because when you're on a streaming
service or on any platform they have
their own problems yeah and because
they're all owned by larger and larger
corporations
um they have to they can't do anything
that wiggles too much
so they have just too many concerns and
that's the way i look at it it's not
like oppression it's just like they're
too they're too mixed in with other [ __ ]
to be my boss because i want to be able
to [ __ ] around and have fun yeah so you
know and so for me i mean i've been
doing this since like 2010 when i put my
first special on my website
um and i like it i like the way the
feeling of it everybody that's bought a
ticket to one of my shows or has bought
one of my shows is on my email list so
they get told
um it's different now because social
media's and the algorithm is a kind of a
giant suck
it's like it does suck it does well it's
like everything is directed to you
you're told what's coming next by the
algorithm it's tailored to each person
and it's hard
people have less of an impulse to look
around
and to find their own [ __ ] you know
nobody picks up a flyer anymore what is
this strange thing you know going to
midnight movies the kind of way that
people use to find things outside of the
corporate
sort of old algorithm of advertising
now they can just kind of just keeps
coming to your phone so you know what's
coming so i think though that people are
starting to want to make more of an
effort
to find their own [ __ ] to find something
that's not you know yeah that's not in
that thing so i that's why i like to
keep my website the same in the same
model in the same way i've always done
it
because we keep getting more people that
you know and that's the feeling we got
when the movie was in the theater it's
not like the other [ __ ] that's out right
now
it's not a marvel movie
and it's not about a black girl with one
leg who persevered and it's not
you know it's about a white guy with two
legs that perseveres yeah exactly who
didn't persevere that well but who did
did his best well see the film for god's
sake yeah that's right